this was a journey to one of the most
secretive places on earth
we started in onesome on North Korea's
East Coast the 14 carriages of this
train staffed by soldiers of the Korean
People's Army ahead a 400 kilometer
journey north into the mountains
government minders escorted us at all
times
all the window blinds were pulled shut
and we were ordered not to open them but
we filmed some of this rarely seen
countryside on our way our train was
bound for palm gowri the heart of North
Korea's nuclear weapons program no
journalists had ever seen it Sky News
was the only UK broadcaster invited 11
hours later travelling through the night
we arrived at je Dockery a small station
near the test site we've been invited to
watch plumberry be destroyed it was
meant to be a gesture of goodwill ahead
of the u.s. North Korean summit that
gesture was spurned by President Donald
Trump the talks canceled at this point
neither we nor the North Koreans knew
that was coming Hungary the North
Koreans have detonated six nuclear
weapons to date since 2006 all of them
in tunnels underneath these mountains
we've driven for an hour and a half to
get here we weren't allowed to take
pictures on the way they delete asunder
footage we did tape but this is what
we've come here to see this tunnel the
scene of five nuclear weapons exploded
since 2009
now we're about to go in those five
tests include North Korea's biggest to
date only in September last year thought
to be a massive hydrogen bomb
eight times as powerful as the one that
destroyed Hiroshima inside it had been
wired to blow up the elaborate
explosives placed front and center for
us to see this man is the deputy
director of North Korea's nuclear
weapons Institute and holds the rank of
general
he's on three Smita all the way here he
told us that we'd see three tunnels
collapse the engines are sealed and the
surrounding buildings destroyed to
observe that we first had to retreat to
a safe distance we hiked half an hour up
the mountain at the top a purpose-built
viewing platform for journalists and
officials alike facility
the observation tower going up now we
weren't quite sure what to expect you
can feel the waves you can feel the dust
it's a big show for us it's a big show
for the world it's designed to give the
impression that North Korea is serious
about these negotiations officials
immediately declared the tunnel
completely destroyed and invited us to
inspect the debris this is the wreckage
of the observation center that stood a
bit earlier that's what's left of the
North tunnel where the North Koreans
exploded five nuclear warheads as you
can see there are a lot of journalists
around that point they've invited us to
come and have a look at the wreckage
rather than experts rather than weapons
inspectors to my eye that building looks
relatively new was it used as an
observation center it's really hard to
tell the wind picked up so we put on our
masks protection against potentially
breathing in particles of radioactive
dust it was a precaution the North
Koreans had confiscated our radiation
detecting equipment so we had no idea
what had been released by the explosion
the North Korean officers from the
nuclear weapons program kept emphasizing
that these tunnels were still usable
that they could detonate a bomb within
them tomorrow instead they were telling
them into tombs I was told these bags
contain plastic explosives
the detonations came quickly several
North Koreans
I spoke to made the same point why do
people say this is just for show why do
they doubt our sincerity well much of
this was for show log cabins can be
rebuilt tunnels can be excavated
entirely new test sites constructed
North Korea has plenty of mountains but
this is a regime that understands the
importance and use of images both at
home and abroad our presence here was
meticulously filmed for propaganda
purposes North Korea was counting on
images like this to keep Donald Trump at
the negotiating table
the rocks were still coming down as they
declared boom Gary closed the general
said that the dismantling of the site
was transparent that it attested once
again to the proactive and peace-loving
efforts of North Korea your deputy
director talked about transparency how
can we verify that the tunnels inside
have also been shot you told us we'd
seen it clearly enough with our own eyes
the explosion had come from inside the
tunnel we did see all three tunnel
entrances closed but it's impossible for
us to know the extent of the
dismantlement still North Korea opened
its most secret place to the world then
took it apart and then the summit was
canceled who knows how to pick up the
pieces
Tom Cheshire Sky News at punggye-ri
nuclear test site in North Korea